Vladimirovich, before you have time to answer,
we still have one video on this topic,
very impressive, I suggest you
watch Vladimir Vladimirovich
Hello, I am a student and study at
St. Petersburg State
University, I want to ask Is it true that
you have many
doubles and how do you feel about the
dangers that  brings
artificial intelligence and neural networks into our lives,
thank you
Yes, I see you can be
like me and speak in my voice, but I
thought and decided that only one person should look like me and
speak in my voice,
and that person will be me, just like that,
one of ours  kids shul once upon a time here's
what concerns artificial
intelligence